voilà Monsieur bonsoir La Victoire en
chantant pour l'équipe de France de
handball pour la première fois de son
histoire championne d'Europe une
médaille d'or bien méritée face à
l'Espagne qui s'est incliné 23 à 31 les
tricoleurs avaient des ailes pas prêt à
se laisser impressionner par l'Espagne
qui pourtant était invaincu depuis 7
match championne du monde en titre
Julien Benedetto et soudain les grands
gaillards se mirent à pleurer les hand
baleur français connaissaient le goût de
leur mondial les voici champions
d'Europe pour la première fois et c'est
aussi
beau on avait rêvé de cette ambiance on
avait rêvé de ces médailles et
aujourd'hui c'est plus des rêve c'est
c'est la réalité donc il y a rien à dire
c'est c'est le bonheur absolu on les
avait laissé être favoris et après on a
mis on a mis une t à tout le monde donc
donc voilà c'est simple on a montré
qu'on était vraiment les meilleurs et
les meilleurs en début de match sont
espagnol la France est à la peine face
au jeu rapide des champions du monde en
titre mené de TR buts les Bleus sont
alors portés par le bras en acier de
Nicola Karabatic qui donne a siens 4
buts d'avance à la
mi-temps de la
profondeur en deè mi-temp meilleur est
un aim qui atre tous les ballons le
gardien des Bleus cur les tireurs
espagnols la France peut dérouler en
attaque et s'envoler vers un succès
presque facile 31 à
23 au panthéon du sport tricolore les
bleus du handball sont désormais assis à
côté des bleus du foot champion du monde
champion d'Europe un doublé pour
l'éternité